[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen welcome to
politics and prize on this balmy spring
evening my name is John and I work here
in the store before we get started if
you could please silence your phones you
shall have my eternal gratitude and just
to let you know this evening we are
recorded and we want to make sure that
your questions are recorded as well for
posterity you'll see two decidedly
there's a microphone so when we have our
question-and-answer session tonight if
you could please speak directly into the
microphone to answer your question I
would appreciate it finally once the
event is over and if you could please do
us the favor of folding your chairs and
placing them against any hard service
once again you'll have my eternal
gratitude thank you
so Charles Whelan is the reason why so
many of you are voluntarily spending
your Tuesday evening listening about
monetary policy my favorite description
of him is the San Francisco Chronicle's
as the best math teacher you never had
and formally current formerly a
correspondent for The Economist mr.
Whelan went on to write naked economics
and naked statistics and was widely
praised for ruthlessly stripping away at
the jargon and obfuscation beloved so
many economic commentators to produce
clear and entertaining explanations of
concept that had been made to appear far
more obscure than they should be I think
it takes somebody very smart to make
money seem so simple and Charles Whelan
pulls it off starting with the absurdity
of the whole premise of money the little
pieces of paper we obsess over and going
on to look at the reasons behind money
why money is good and why it can go bad
reading naked money is to see economic
patterns fall into place and hazy
notions about the roles of fiscal
institutions come into sharp focus at a
time when the mechanisms upon which the
global financial system relies are under
intense scrutiny I think the best thing
we can do before we attack or defend the
system is try to understand it we're
fortunate that Charles Whelan is here to
lay it out for us he writes without bias
armed with entertaining analogies that
anyone can follow and paint a picture of
the extraordinary societal consensus
that is money just remember when you
realize how bizarre those crumpled
pieces of paper and your wallet really
are will happily swap them for brand-new
books I think that's a pretty good deal
my child really well thank you very much
for coming out you may be disappointed
to realize that there'll be no nudity
and this isn't about getting rich but
naked money is now I guess the third and
what we're describing as the naked
trilogy there will be a box set I'm told
and never if you'd asked me in graduate
school did I imagine that I would be
here speaking or that I would have
written three books all with the word
naked in the title but they they
happened in many ways by accident I'll
give you the origin of the series then
I'll talk a little bit more about this
book naked economics was written as
close to by accident as you can when it
comes to writing a book I was trying to
write a book on the gambling industry I
was at the time the Midwest
correspondent for The Economist so he's
based out of Chicago this was 1997 and
for those of you you may or may not know
if he's spending time in the Midwest if
you go back to the early 90s in places
like Iowa it was still illegal to have a
bingo game at a church if there was any
money involved when you fast forward it
to about the midpoint of my tenure at
The Economist's there were 19 riverboat
casinos and myriad other forms of
gambling so I had along with in other
states in my territory you had an
explosion of Indian casinos you had all
kinds of other forms of gambling that
were spreading in rapid clip so I
figured this would be a really exciting
thing to write a book about and I'd
written columns about compulsive
gambling casino design the politics of
state governments and Indian tribes and
so on while I was trying unsuccessfully
to peddle this book I was hired to teach
a class at Northwestern at the middle
school of journalism about economics and
finance for journalists which I thought
would be a great contribution to the
field so I call like but I couldn't find
a book that would be appropriate for
journalists all of the things that I had
used for eat to study economics were
overly technical long dense and so on so
I called my agent the woman
unsuccessfully peddling the gambling
book and I said look you know more about
the publishing industry than I do
clearly there must be a book on
economics that expresses how important
these ideas are that doesn't get bogged
down in the math and the graphs and all
the rest of it this is really fun stuff
there's a long pause
she said no there's not but you're going
to write it and it's going to be called
economics for poets and I'm going to
read it and that was we took a detour
the gambling book was never written
someone needs to write it because
there's all kinds of interesting stuff
going on there but this book came to
fill a void the second book naked
statistics in some ways was the same it
was although I didn't know it right
about the time that big data came along
I had taken a lot of Statistics classes
in fact I had taken two statistics
classes from people with won the Nobel
Prize and they were arguably the two
worst classes I've ever taken in my life
and this you know like ikana this is in
some ways I was even more frustrated
than I was with economics because
statistics is actually very intuitive at
bottom if you want to understand why
polling works you can do you can figure
out all the coefficients and do the math
and we'll use a lot of Greek letters or
you can just say if you've got a bowl of
soup big bowl of soup and you mix it up
appropriately and you take a small
spoonful you're going to know what the
whole thing tastes like I mean that is
and if you're sitting if you haven't
stirred it up like we've been doing
lately you know with internet polls and
people not answering their phones
it won't take taste like the rest of the
pot right so they're a whole bunch of
things so negative statistics again was
kind of born by accident and this book
is the same way naked money was born out
of the idea that there are three related
concepts that are covered the book all
woefully misunderstood I'm not going to
go into in great depth but for example
we have two presidential candidates both
of whom have embraced the gold standard
when the University of Chicago Booth
School of Business if you're interested
in economics at all there's this thing
called the I international global marks
IgM panel and they have a sample of I
want to say 50 economists it's nicely
ideological divide eeeh logically
diverse it's a tremendous group of
economists and what
IgM does
is pull these economists on issues of
the day does trade - doesn't kill
manufacturing jobs today they asked what
the Bureau of Labor Statistics was
actually worth the money we spend on
it's a random collection but when this
panel was asked whether the United
States would be better off if we went
back to a gold standard it is the only
time in all the years that I followed
the survey that the answer was unanimous
and it was no so it should cause
everybody a little concern that we have
every economist of note in the panel
saying one thing and a high proportion
of presidential candidates saying
something else so the book therefore was
designed to serve this need and it's the
things that covers our money and I'm
actually going to read something from
the beginning of the book about what is
money and money by the way is such a
strange concept that there would be
times when I was working on the book
where I fully understood it and it was
go away or just leave my Brando
understand it anymore because it's so
strange I mean at the end of the day
it's really an issue of trust it comes
down to web money you know money works
when other people think money will work
and then there's banking and banking as
we learned in 2008 has inherent
frailties I mean the thing that will
never change about finance is that it is
basically about intermediating lenders
and borrowers right you can do that with
conventional banks you can do that with
the repurchase market you can do with
shadow banks you do with all kinds of
institutions but at the end of the day
people who have extra capital are giving
it away temporarily they're renting it
to somebody else and they expect to get
a rental rate and the people who need it
are borrowing it which is actually a
terrific thing a woman called me from
Time magazine today and she said is
there ever a situation with debt is a
good thing the debt is always well my
own that is usually a good thing right
it means you can buy a house before
you're 65 you can afford to go to
college you can do anything and all
those people with extra capital don't
have to put it in the basement and earn
zero return it just has some problems
when all those people who loan the money
would like to get it back now and all
those people who have it cannot possibly
pay it back even if they put it to good
use
if you've ever seen it's a wonderful
life that is pretty much most of what
you need to know about the financial
system and while 2008 is still deep in
our memories obviously 1929 was
fundamentally similar in terms of the
being a banking crisis much much worse
but then the history United States is a
history of banking crises beginning at
the end of the 1700s there are panics
you've never even heard of in the 1830s
the 1860s the 1890s the panic of 1907
that led to the creation of the Fed and
they all have it there at their core the
nature of Finance which is people
suddenly want their money back you can't
give it back to them all at the same
time there's a panic healthy
institutions become unhealthy and so on
we've seen that movie and then the last
piece is the central banks and the
Federal Reserve in particular in the
case of United States and the central
bank is of course the institution with
full oversight over the money they're
the ones entrusted with protecting the
value of that paper currency which is
either worth nothing or lots depending
on how you look at it and I I did love
the tweet that went out for politics and
prose which is if you think it's worth
let's give it to us and we'll give you
books in exchange it's not worthless it
has no intrinsic value you can't take
your your paper money anywhere here in
Washington and wave it around and demand
gold or silver you can you just aren't
going to get it you might get escorted
out of the building or what-have-you but
it's by no means worthless and their
money you know not just here anywhere up
and down the strip people will gladly
take it and they will give you a
relatively predictable amount of goods
and services in return central bank is
responsible for that and of course it's
also it shares responsibility with the
Treasury and other agencies for
oversight of this frail banking system
so they're the ones charged with
protecting the system that has as its
core this fundamental weakness so those
are the three pieces of it so I'll start
with just reading a couple pages from
the beginning what is money and then
I'll turn to the very end which is what
we've learned about central banking and
I'll just kind of paraphrase some of the
lessons and then we'll have some time
for questions and answers so the chapter
one is what is money in 2009 North Korea
did something unusual even by North
Korean standards has a high bar or a low
bar Penhale you look at the
nation issued a new currency that lopped
two zeros off all the bills thus one one
of the new currency was declared
equivalent to 100 one of the old
currency this is not a particularly new
trick assorted countries in the past
have issued new currencies with fewer
zeros as a tool for in fighting
inflation in 1994 Brazil created an
entirely new currency the rial to
replace the inflation battered Cruzeiro
rail the government announced that each
tiny new rail would be worth roughly
twenty seven hundred and fifty Cruzeiro
ray eye none of this is inherently good
or bad for consumers as long as the old
currency can be freely swapped for the
new currency imagine if the United
States had no dollar bill but instead
priced everything in pennies one day the
government announced that pennies would
no longer be accepted as legal tender
instead 100 pennies could be swapped for
a new currency the dollar after which
all prices would be quoted in dollars a
product that used to cost 200 WA now
cost 2 in terms of purchasing power
nothing would change people who had lots
of pennies before would now have lots of
dollars bank accounts would be even
easier to convert every account would
just lose two digits prices would look
lower hence the tool for fighting
inflation but in terms of accumulated
wealth rich people would still be rich
and poor people would still be poor only
in dollars rather than pennies anyone
over the age of 6 recognizes that five
dollars is no different than five
hundred pennies and even the
six-year-olds can only be fooled a few
times we would all just have to carry
fewer coins in our pockets stores would
no longer accept pennies but if you
happen to discover 300 of them under the
cushions of your couch you could always
take them to a bank and swap them for
dollars Brazilians had nearly a year to
convert their old Cruzeiro ray eye to
the new ray eye some European nations
such as Germany has said they will
forever exchange old coins and notes
joyce mark for euros even though the
country gave up the deutsche mark for
the euro more than a decade and a half
ago but north korea is not like other
countries when north korea engineered
its currency reform the government
announced that only a limited amount of
the old currency could be swapped for
the new currency about six hundred and
ninety dollars at the official exchange
rate
we should take a small detour about the
official exchange rate you can imagine
that North Korea pegs the North Korean
Wan at whatever the great leader says it
should be worth in dollars
most people would much rather have the
dollars so the official exchange rate is
worth about $35 at the black market rate
anyone holding large amounts of old
currency would see much of their
accumulated wealth destroyed and of
course that was exactly the point the
North Korean government had become
increasingly good activities outside the
country's official ration based economy
black market traders were sitting on
large stashes of cash with a stroke of a
government pen or whatever Korea's
supreme leader does to promulgate
legislation the government confiscated
most of that illicitly accumulated
wealth of course many ordinary North
Koreans hoping to avoid starvation
during the winter had also accumulated
large stocks of cash after the
announcement of the currency reform the
sparse news that leaked out of North
Korea made reference to quote chaos in
markets and rail stations end quote as
savers rushed home to swap old money for
new North Koreans in only 24 hours to
convert their allotted quota of old
currency to new currency a defector told
Barbara Demick a writer of the new for
The New Yorker in one day all your money
was lost people were taken to the
hospital in shock the North Korean
government had taken money with value
and rendered it worthless that's a very
curious power now one little side note
is there are a lot of North Korean
stories in here in part because North
Korea is so strange it just stands in
juxtaposition to all kinds of things but
my resource assistant over the course of
the book developed a fascination with
North Korea and the last time I saw him
as your finish up finishing up the book
he said I'm going to North Korea I just
got to get there and I thought well you
know this may or may not be a good idea
he didn't really did kind of disappear
for a long stretch and the next time I
heard from him I got this hand addressed
envelope in my mailbox at Dartmouth and
inside was a 5,000 Hwan note along with
the story of how it smuggled it out and
a Kim jong-un postage stamp
which not everybody gets right so but he
did escape the country with his 5000
note that one note okay he's back in the
United States last I checked alright so
we're back North Korean Hwan which is
even more curious when juxtaposed
against what was happening in the United
States at exactly the same time in
response to the 2008 financial crisis
the Federal Reserve was aggressively
quote injecting liquidity and quote into
the financial system the concept of
liquidity will be explored in greater
depth in the book but for now the basic
point is that the Federal Reserve was
doing everything in its power to lower
interest rates so that struggling banks
businesses and consumers would have
easier access to credit after the real
estate bust here's the part that is
almost North Korean in its weirdness the
Federal Reserve accomplished its task by
creating new money from nowhere there's
a windowless room at the Federal Reserve
Bank of New York it really is windowless
where traders literally created new
electronic money and used it to buy
billions of dollars of financial assets
between January of 2008 and January of
2014 the Fed injected roughly three
trillion of new money into the American
economy one minute the money did not
exist
the next minute a trader acting at the
behest of the Fed bought bonds belonging
to assorted private institutions and
paid for those securities by
transferring electronic funds to the
accounts of the selling firms new money
money that did not exist just seconds
earlier click that is the sound of a guy
sitting at his computer in New York
creating a billion dollars and using it
to buy assets from Citibank click click
that's 2 billion more while North Korea
Supreme Leader was taking money with
value and rendering it useless the Fed
was doing the opposite creating money
out of nothing neither the North Korean
Won nor the United States dollar has any
intrinsic value one cannot take either
currency to the government that issued
it and demand something tangible in
return such as gold or rice or cooking
oil although at least in the United
States you would not be sent to a labor
camp for asking
North Korea could wipe out money and the
United States could create it because
money in both countries is just paper or
increasingly bits and bytes on a
computer screen and that brings us to
the third wacky thing going on at
roughly the same time that North Korea
was destroying money and the United
States was creating it American
prisoners were conducting many of their
transactions using pouches of mackerel
yes the oily fish prison inmates in the
United States are not allowed to possess
cash instead they typically have account
to the commissary where small items can
be purchased with no caste circulating
the goods sold in the commissary can be
used as currency books of stamp power
bars and so on as has been the case
throughout history this kind of Commerce
becomes easier when there's an informal
agreement on a single unit of account
such as cigarettes in the prisoner of
war camps during World War two the item
that has emerged as the gold standard
for trade in America in prison since the
federal smoking ban which move
cigarettes out is the pouch of mackerel
or the Mac it comes in a pouch rather
than a can so prisoners will not sharpen
the container and stab one another the
macro purge pouches are portable and
storable which is a nice feature for any
currency curiously the mackerel has
little appeal outside of prison even at
discount retailers but behind bars
mackerel out sells tuna crab chicken and
oysters in part because a pouch of
mackerel happens to sell for roughly $1
in the canteen so it's relatively easy
to think in terms of dollars while using
Mac's
unlike the dollar or the one the
mackerel does have some intrinsic value
you can always eat it in fact if the
North Korean or American economies ran
on mackerel neither the Supreme Leader
nor the Federal Reserve could have done
what they did the Supreme Leader cannot
go on television and declare that all
mackerel is now worthless it's still
mackerel you might get arrested if you
try and trade it for a winter coat but
you can always keep it in the basement
and eat it for dinner during the
periodic famines one cannot print out
something worthless that has worth true
government could try to confiscate old
mackerel but that's a different and much
more difficult tasks similarly the
United States Federal Reserve cannot
instantaneously generate millions of
pouches of mackerel where none
previously existed no one in a
windowless room at the Fed can push a
button and have pouches mackerel show up
at seeing Bank
click-click-click that is the sound of
no mackerel being created alright so
we've got this very strange concept of
money and so this is when you know
periodically my head would just go like
I can't quite figure out what's going on
and here's kind of what it comes down to
money depends on confidence consider the
curious case of Indian rupees according
to the Federal Reserve Bank of India any
soiled or torn rupee is legal tender as
long as it has two intact serial numbers
that's by the way the same is true with
US currencies have you ever gotten
change in Starbucks and the head George
Washington Ted's missing or their phone
numbers written on it one of their two
serial numbers it's fine to tape
together can be stapled together which
is of course why you're willing to
accept it same in India if you present a
crumpled dirty or torn note at an Indian
Bank the law states that the disfigured
bill must be replaced with a crisp new
one yet on the streets of Mumbai you
will find it very difficult to get
anyone to accept a torn or overly worn
rupee note even if the serial numbers
are clearly visible and intact not
shopkeepers not taxi drivers not street
vendors and therefore no one who expects
to do business with shopkeepers taxi
drivers or street vendors will accept
them no one wants to be the sucker who
has to schlep the soil bill to a bank to
exchange it
of course if people just accepted the
soiled notes no one would have to slep
them to the bank at all in the United
States I've accepted torn dollar bills
crumpled dollar bills dollar bills with
pictures and phone numbers on them bills
taped together and even a dollar bill
with George Washington's face cut out if
it's got two serial numbers than the guy
at Starbucks handed to me I will take it
as will everyone else which is why I
will take it but not in India no one
will accept torn rupees because no one
will accept torn rupees of course when I
traveled India I refused to accept
rupees in bad condition therefore
perpetuating the whole phenomenon now I
mean it just keeps getting weird so in
Somalia in the early 2000s the opposite
was happening money with no legal value
was thriving the currency of choice
all transactions with the Somali
shilling which was not legal tender
dollars were used for large transactions
due to a long-running civil war the
Central Bank of Somalia Somalia had shut
down a transitional federal government
was supposedly responsible for monetary
policy but that entity's Authority
barely extended past Mogadishu from the
legal standpoint at the time the Somali
shilling had roughly the same legitimacy
as monopoly money the notes in
circulation had been issued two decades
earlier by a government that no longer
existed as The Economist noted use of
paper money has normally taken to be an
expression of faith in the government
that issues issues it in the Somali case
for several decades there was
effectively no government yet the
currency just pieces of papers marched
steadily on why the short answer is that
people accepted smaller shillings
because people accepted Somali shillings
if you poked a little harder there were
several reasons first the shillings were
useful as a medium of exchange for small
transactions just as prison inmates are
accustomed to pricing and conducting
transactions and max the small ways were
used to buying tea and bread with
shillings everyone had a pretty good
idea how many shillings a small bar of
soap bought to cost second somalia has a
strong clan and kinship system in the
absence of a government this system
functions as a strong social glue that
undergirded the faith in the currency
there was an expectation among members
of these networks that others in the
network would accept shillings as the
economists explained in the same article
paper currencies always need tacit
consent from their users that they will
exchange bills for actual stuff but in
Somalia this pact is rather stronger an
individual who clouds the system risks
risks jeopardizing trust in both himself
and his clan and then finally the total
absence of a functioning government was
a good thing for the value of paper
money in this case the supply of
shillings was more or less fixed because
there was no government to print more of
them in contrast quasi functioning
governments often often recklessly print
currency as they struggle to stay in
power
take the Belarus Belarusian ruble which
was introduced in the 1990s and became
known as the bunny partly because of the
hair engraved on the note but also for
its unique ability to propagate
the only growth in the supply of Somali
shillings during the Civil War came from
counterfeiters and even the high number
of quality fakes was limited because of
the specialized Talent equipment and
materials needed to make them for this
reason businesses and even Somali banks
sometimes accepted high-quality
counterfeits
which created a certain mind-bending
logic as explained in one news account
quote an imitation of a thing which is
already of notional value turns out to
be worth something
it's like a bank willing to accept
counterfeit monopoly money not just fake
money but fake fake money all right so
this is weird um in here you know the
only picture in the book this is a real
sign that appeared in South Africa which
is close to Zimbabwe in Zimbabwe had one
of the great hyperinflations in the
1990s I have on my desk at Dartmouth a
hundred trillion dollar note from
Zimbabwe which I think I bought for $10
and that's mostly because of its novelty
value and because it was in good shape
what the sign says says toilet paper
only to be used in this toilet no
cardboard no cloth no newspaper and no
zim dollars the lower bill to become so
useless that they were better used as
toilet paper than for actual currency so
we reach a paradox here that modern
money the currencies used in United
States Canada Europe Japan China and
every other developed country can be
produced in unlimited quantities so you
have always the potential of the
Zimbabwe problem they are fiat
currencies meaning that they have value
because the government's that issue them
declare them to be legal tender a
century ago those same countries use
commodity money gold silver some
combination of two how is it that in the
name of progress all the world's most
economically vibrant nations have moved
from money with intrinsic value and
finite supply to money with no intrinsic
value that can be produced in unlimited
supply we don't even need quality paper
and specialized ink anymore I note that
because in a lot of the cases of
hyperinflation particularly Latin
America in the 70s and 80s the only
constraint on how much money they
printed was whether they could get
enough of the high-quality paper that
they needed because they weren't
so sometimes they be important the
largest import I think it was in
Argentina at the height of the
hyperinflation was paper from Europe to
produce more currency so it's very very
strange and so let me finish this with a
brief theoretical detour if we could
design the perfect money from scratch
what would it look like obviously we'd
have to serve the three functions
described earlier unit of account and we
haven't got through this but basically
you can think in terms of this money and
in queue a we can talk about things like
Bitcoin and we can discuss whether
that's money or not it's not a store of
value which means if you have wealth in
this money is it still going to be
around and worth it's roughly the same
amount next year or ten years now and
there's a medium of exchange since
something that's reasonably easy to
conduct commerce with to that end we
would look for a commodity that's
portable durable divisible and
predictably scarce gold performs admiral
admirably by all those measures but gold
has its drawbacks too gold may make for
great jewelry but it has limited other
uses when an asteroid strikes earth and
you're stuck in the basement with your
accumulated life savings in gold you
will not feel particularly rich by
comparison the guy with bottled water
and the cans of refried beans will look
like Bill Gates asteroids aside the
supply of gold will not necessarily
increase at the same rate as the overall
economy
if melting ice in the Arctic exposed new
gold deposits there be a spike in the
quantity of gold relative to other
products leading to inflation this
actually happened during the colonial
period whenever there are big gold or
silver dispositive positives discovered
in the new world or as it was called
from the European standpoint they
drained all back and prices would go up
several fold even if the supply were to
increased by just the right amount the
same rate as economic growth creating
stable prices under normal circumstances
a high proportion of the world's known
gold reserves are in China and Russia if
we were designing an optical optimal
currency we would not entrust control
the money supply to foreign powers whose
interest do not always align with our
own so gold has some issues and someone
needs to ask the presidential candidates
on record as saying we go back to the
gold standard why especially given some
of their other positions they would like
to
turn our money over to commodity where
we control a relatively small fraction
of the world's reserves so tonight
instead opts for different commodities
such as bags of rice or wheat these are
nicely divisible and not controlled by
rice Russia or China we could fix the
portability problem one could imagine
the commodity bank where bags of rice
and wheat are stored and then paper
currency is issued against those bags we
could all conduct transactions using
this handy paper currency or its
electronic equivalent but unlike our
current dollars each certificate would
be redeemable at the commodity bank for
something with intrinsic value that
would give us a portable currency a
predictable unit of account a reasonable
store of value presuming you can protect
the rice from rats and no risk of
hyperinflation but do you really want
all of your wealth tied up in rice or
wheat these crops are less predictable
store value than you might think suppose
a farmer invents a new technology that
trebles or quadruples rice yields as has
happened throughout history your life
savings are now devalued by the fact
that the supply of rice has increased
dramatically or conversely there may be
some rice scourge that wipes out the
accumulated stores even under normal
circumstances we have no reason to
believe that the supply the chosen
commodity will increase at the same rate
as economic growth meaning the prices
will rise or fall depending on its
quantity relative to other goods would
you want to write a long term contract
denominated in rice if you are not sure
how valuable rice would be relative to
other goods ten twenty or thirty years
from now fortunately there is an easy
fix for the uncertainty surrounding the
supply of any single commodity a
currency backed by a basket of
commodities suppose each commodity
dollar could be exchanged for a kilo of
rice a gallon of gasoline a quart of
milk six songs on iTunes and so on the
accounting would become a little more
difficult but consumers would grow
accustomed to the system as long as the
value of the currency remains stable the
holders of these commodity dollars would
be insulated and against any sudden
increase or decrease in the supply of
any single commodity the currency would
have real well-defined purchasing power
the broader the basket of commodities
against which the currency is backed the
more stable the value of that currency
and more highly correlated it will be
with growth in the economy overall
remember this is a theoretical exercise
let's dream a little
imagine a currency that could be taken
to some dank backroom and exchange for
predictable quantities of food energy
electronics cars bicycles the money
would not just be backed by gold or ice
that we backed by a sample of all the
goods and services you regularly consume
better yet the purchasing power this
fancy new money visa vie this diverse
basket of goods would not fluctuate by
more than a few percent a year you would
have a very good idea of what your money
would buy in terms of goods and services
today and also well into the future this
cool hypothetical money would deliver
all the benefits of money backed by a
single commodity purchasing power that's
steady over time without the drawbacks
each unit of money would be redeemable
for a broad basket of goods at a
predictable rate over a long period of
time okay here is the mind-bending part
of this exercise what I have just
described is the dollar the euro the yen
and many other fiat currencies yes they
are just paper or bits and bytes but
when the government issuing those
currencies do their jobs properly those
pieces of paper and their electronic
equivalents have a predictable value
relative to a broad basket of goods and
services even into the distant future
therein lies the challenge of modern
money central banks can create money
from nothing they can also make money go
away click click click that is the sound
of central bankers growing the money
supply or shrinking it responsible
central bankers can manipulate a fiat
currency in ways that stem financial
panics and promote stable economic
growth irresponsible policymakers can
use the same awesome power to create
money so recklessly the bills become
worth less than toilet paper history has
seen some of each so that's money we'll
skip baggy and I'll just briefly go
through the last chapter which is called
doing central banking better and this
chapter is kind of organized along three
very simple principles the first is we
were right which in its all went around
when I was in grad school what was I
taught
in grad school about central banking
that was confirmed in 2008 and there
were a couple things one is we need a
lender of last resort the Federal
Reserve's job is to be banker for the
bankers when there is a financial panic
- which finances always and always will
be prone having the Fed step in is what
stops the panic if they do it correctly
and there's a whole chapter on 1929 and
2008 in 1929 we failed to do that in
2008 I would argue and I do argue that
we did it reasonably well a central
bank's political independence is crucial
to its effectiveness it's interesting
because when I was in grad school I was
taught that the reason central bank's
need to be politically insulated is
because there will always be pressure
from the politicians to create more
inflation because inflation operates
with a lag so in most cases politicians
who would like to win an election can
tell the central bank if it's not
independent print some more money people
think they're richer then I'll get
elected then they'll realize prices have
gone up and nothing's changed but the
zeroes on the currency and that's pretty
much been the story throughout history
2008 was different in that there was so
much political hostility to creating
more money and propping up the banks and
a lot of the political resistance came
from the political right warning of
hyperinflation but the same basic thing
which is the Federal Reserve needs to be
unreal ative lee unencumbered from
politics so they can do what it believes
is necessary to stabilize the system and
protect the currency and throughout 2008
and since then the value of the dollar
has remained remarkably stable a modest
inflation target is better than zero
that's what I described a greater length
in the book but as we have seen even
since 2008 if you aim for perfectly
stable prices the Federal Reserve can
only cut interest rates to zero we
thought we've nothing them- in parts of
the world when you talk about that if
you have an inflation target of say 2
percent which is what the United States
now has if interest rates go to zero
they've really gone to negative 2
percent so you may not be paying an
interest but the money you're paying
back on your loan is worth 2 percent
less than it was when you borrowed it
which is effectively a negative interest
rate so there are many practical reasons
for modest and stable inflation target
the central bank should regular
eight the institutions for which it is
the lender of last resort so if you're
the one who bails out people when
there's a metaphorical fire you should
have the right to make them put in fire
alarms right em we can talk much more
about that in the Q&A period if you like
but there is certainly a symmetry there
now what things we learn to do thousand
eight there are plenty of effective
tools after the Fed hits the zero bound
so once interest rates get hit zero we
had qe1 qe2 qe3 a whole bunch of other
fancy tools that can be used to push
down long-term interest rates things
that were at most hypothetical crazy
ideas when I was in grad school Bank of
Japan tried them first the Fed has done
obviously a number of them we need to
pay more attention to systemic risk
there were a fair number of people
around 2005 who had a pretty good idea
that the real estate market was
overheated there are very very few
people who had any sense of how that
collapse in the real estate market would
spread so viciously throughout the
global system so every if you've seen a
big short that's the best illustration
of how it was you know those toxic
assets and the bogus rating agencies
attaching values to those assets that's
what happened but nobody really saw that
coming so somebody arguably the central
bank or the central bank in conjunction
with the Treasury needs to be looking
across the system and thinking okay if
that house catches on fire even if we
know the person there is irresponsible
we don't want to bail them out what
happens to the rest of the neighborhood
and it remains to be seen whether we
have successfully done that or whether
we just changed the nature of the next
crisis transparency and good
communication matter at the Fed as they
do in most institutions so one of the
most curious things about the Fed is how
being opaque and secretive was
considered to be a strength for long
period of time if you remember secrets
of the temple which is written by
William Greider he described the Fed as
more secretive than the CIA and so on
this has many bad things about it one of
which is the markets are looking to try
and figure out what the central bank is
doing so why in the world would you hide
it from them instead you're trying to
Telegraph your intentions and the second
is that has spawned all kinds of
conspiracy theories I've done a
bunch of talk-radio over the last week
and you would not believe some of the
questions that have gotten my favorite
conspiracy theory is a JP Morgan who was
one of the original architects of the
Federal Reserve Act of 1913 deliberately
sunk built and sunk the Titanic because
opponents of the Federal Reserve were on
the ship and he had booked passage and
cancelled in last-minute they went down
with the ship he got the Federal Reserve
and apparently there was an there was a
novel in the 1890s about a ship and it
was called like the titania that was
built and ran into an iceberg and sunk
and this is where I got the idea
Perry's also true that the Federal
Reserve killed Kennedy there had to be a
Kennedy
you know assassination conspiracy theory
or you're not trying very hard because
he was about to crack down on the
central bank and they were fighting back
so the fact that the central bank is
trying to be more public minded and this
is one of the things that Ben Bernanke
did even before the crisis is arguably
good thing in this probably room for
them to improve on that front and then
the last is stuff that we're still
learning and we're not sure and so one
is can the Federal Reserve unwind its
balance sheet in a way that does not
cause the next crisis so qe1 qe2 qe3 the
other extraordinary measures were all
accomplished with the Fed creating all
that new money click-click click-click
that new money is now sitting in
reserves on the balance sheet of banks
throughout the system it's not the money
supply hasn't exploded in parks Amman
loaned it out but they might and if they
start to do that can the Federal Reserve
unwind this huge stash of reserves they
believe that they can but that is as of
yet unproven so we've gone into new
territory with regard to the
aggressiveness with which the Fed has
acted what should the Federal Reserve be
trying to do so the American central
bank is the only one that I know of
that has a dual mandate it is charged
with protecting the purchasing power of
the dollar and also maintaining full
employment most of the time so for
example Paul Volcker we tell you those
are really the same thing the only way
you maximize full employment is by
making sure there's no inflation or
deflation but their periods when there's
room to do things someone like Ben
Bernanke would argue too
employment that wouldn't necessarily be
inflationary there might be a little
inflationary and then those two
objectives come into contact coming to
conflict with one another anytime you
get two objectives there's a potential
conflict so my daughter is about to
start college if I say work hard and
have fun right most of the time those
things are the same but sometimes
they're not and so we're still parsing
what the Fed aux actually ought to be do
ought to be doing and then the last one
is does the central bank operate more
effectively with explicit monetary
policy rules or with the discretion to
act as necessary and this is a somewhat
technical and very political debate
Congress is currently trying to rein in
the Fed audit the Fed which has nothing
to do with whether the Fed is stealing
money and everything to do with the Fed
explaining its decisions on monetary
policy and some of those bills that have
been introduced would say the Fed must
declare a set of rules with which it is
going to act and if it deviates from
those rules going to come report to
Congress on why it has done that some
are even more would take even more
control away from the Fed than that so
I'll stop there on this very important
note that money is important and it's
also very very political and I think you
see that in the presidential race you
see that in Congress and what-have-you
so thank you very much for coming I'd be
happy to answer questions about money
banking central banking or anything else
high gas tea with a boot oh that was a
great talk could you say a little bit
about the impact of the feds you know
creation of several trillion dollars
what that's been perhaps to the stock
market and other asset prices and you
know as they aligned it what that might
mean yeah so this is the literally the
trillion dollar question pun intended so
I mean the feds mission is to protect
the purchasing power of the currency so
many of the critics of this policy
warned of hyperinflation which we
obviously have not seen we haven't even
seen the Fed hitting its inflation
target so by that metric it has not been
a pernicious activity but it is also
true as you alluded to we've had this
bizarre and perhaps unprecedented period
of essentially zero interest rates
negative now interest rates in parts of
the world and that
has all these other consequences some
intended some unintended so ben bernanke
would say and does say that the fact
that low interest rates make asset
prices go up is exactly what it's
supposed to do is one of the channel
they're three channels through which low
interest rates stimulate the economy one
is what everyone thinks about which is
cheaper to borrow and buy things cars
and washing machines alike
the second is it tends to cause your
currency to depreciate so your exports
get cheaper and that puts people back to
work and the third is that other asset
prices go up so buying a house becomes
cheaper because you can borrow less that
gets capitalized into price the houses
stock prices go up and so on I don't
know I'm not sure anybody does what the
effect of all these asset prices
increases might be and other related
things so for example people like Africa
saying that the head of the Reserve Bank
of India has complained well when the US
interest rates get so low money just
goes coursing around the rest of the
world as people look for yield chase
interest rates that's extremely
destabilizing in places like India or
even smaller economies and of course
then when the interest when US starts
raving its Straits is going to cut all
back I think the jury is out on what the
impact is going to be so far we haven't
to my knowledge seen bubbles in those
places but it is you know the law of
unintended consequences probably the
most important and public policy in
general and central banking in
particular so you know I think we will
see whether we've created the next
crisis or mini crisis is something we're
going to be looking for yes when I was
in law school in the early 70s probably
before you were born no I was over there
one there was a lot to talk about the
money supply m1m to the chicago school
and said we you know she should watch
this this was very important and you
never hear about it anymore the Federal
Reserve abandoned the money supply as a
tool and the reason is that Milton
Friedman who was the one focusing on
this later conceded that it did not
track in a one-for-one way with prices
as he had predicted ah big picture lots
more money always leads to more
inflation and that's the Friedman has
famous for saying
money or inflation is everywhere and
always a monetary phenomenon but in the
short run it doesn't track because if
there's a big increase in the money
supply or the Fed is pushing much money
and people are spending less say they're
keeping in the basement then velocity
Goes Down and you won't see a spike in
prices so it's very hard to track the
money supply and know exactly what's
going to happen to prices when Paul
Volcker beat inflation in the 70s almost
single-handedly he abandoned money
supply as a tool and focused just on
interest rates and prices ah and those
are those are more directly observable
tools with prices being imperfect
because there's a lag there too but
better than money supply thank you sure
so at one time there used to be
discussion of fiscal policy and monetary
policy and they were almost regarded as
co-equals in some ways it seems like is
relatively little discussion of managing
the economy through fiscal policy and
the ability of Congress and executive
branch to manage fiscal policy and that
all sorts of demands have been placed on
monetary policy to handle things that at
least theoretically in the past used to
be regarded as this is a great point the
theory has not changed at all
monetary policy and fiscal policy are
still pedals that can brakes that can be
used to the same effects if you're in a
downturn you can lower interest rates
you could also most though not all
economists would argue spend more use
fiscal policy their tax cuts that would
be the Republican flavor or spending
infrastructure would be the Democratic
flavor to stimulate demand to the same
effect now even before 2008 economists
said monetary policy was preferable only
because it was faster and easier the Fed
could do it without having to get
anything through Congress and that's
kind of where we've ended up it's not
and there's still a strong belief that
when monetary policy gets near zero you
should turn to fiscal policy to pick up
the slack at a minimum you should not be
using 50 should not be hitting the brake
on fiscal policy as you're pressing on
the
gasps with monetary policy as you saw in
large parts of the world and I think the
evidence is not unanimous but quite
compelling that austerity turned out to
be counterproductive in a lot of places
so nothing's changed about the theory
all that's happened is essentially the
politics has been very hard to get any
coherent fiscal policy approach here the
small stimulus at the beginning of
Obama's term but you remember how
conflict-ridden that was so if people
are still thinking the same they're just
using monetary policy because it's
easier this is almost a follow-up Obama
really wanted to do a major stimulus and
there were quite a number of economists
who believed that we should be
rebuilding our infrastructure when the
interest rates were so low and prices
were low blah blah blah and as you noted
the bank's just received huge amounts of
money with no obligation there was no
there were no strings attached to that
money so they just lined their pockets
and sat on the money and nothing
happened in the economy as I understand
you know Larry Summers and the others
argued that we couldn't put any strings
on it I'm not really certain what the
arguments was why they were that they
couldn't put the strings on but I would
like your opinion on was it a good idea
not Wood strings have inhibited the
ability to do whatever we think we did
it was a great question I don't know I'm
not a lawyer and so the question is I
don't know the Fed certainly has the
authority to lend money to those
institutions because their member
incisions the Federal Reserve System I
don't know their legal authority to then
put constraints on the banks in part
because remember one thing that was
strange about the way the Fed acted is
many of the banks were not given a
choice as to whether to take the money
or not right and the reason they did
that is we if you remember if you've
seen any of these movies that recreated
the
because if you said are you need the
money you need the money you both have
them runs on your balance sheets
immediately so what we need to do is say
I'm giving you all money so nobody will
know which of you are in trouble so the
fact that you have escaped some of you
in voluntarily taking capital from the
Federal Reserve then makes it more
debatable as to whether I can put
constraints on your what you do with it
whether I can force you to loan it out
whether I can limit bonuses and so on so
the legal I don't know the legal answer
i unequivocally know that they totally
botched the pr side of things and that's
both tarp which would be Congress and
acting but also the Federal Reserve in
that most people had very little
understanding of why this was being done
how bad it would be in the absence of
this and so I think if if we'd had
better acronyms a better explanation of
the fact that these were loans to the
from the Federal Reserve's isn't by the
way the Federal Reserve has been paid
back every loan it made every single one
against all those strings access assets
have been paid back so you know as I've
said oh that's unsatisfying on the legal
front but I absolutely concede your
point that part of what we're seeing on
the political front both Donald Trump
and with Bernie is people are just
really really angry at the pain that was
suffered on Main Street in 2008 and what
they perceive as overly generous
bailouts to Wall Street and people are
not wrong it's just not clear that there
was a better alternative I mean let me
just give you one example of how bad
things were one of these I learned in
writing this book is how close we were
to the financial abyss
every time I spoke to somebody the
closer they were to what was happening
2008 the more scared they were and the
story that encapsulate that in the book
Judd Gregg was the former civil senator
from New Hampshire now former he was the
senior Republican on the Budget
Committee he tells the story right after
Lehman Brothers he was summoned to the
capital like nine o'clock at night on a
Wednesday night or something and Mitch
McConnell walks in Mitch McConnell says
in a black tie Mitch McConnell says the
Fed chair is going to be here in a few
minutes listen carefully
to what he has to say this is story that
Judd Gregg told to my class when he came
in to speak to the class Ben Bernanke
walks in says look you have about 72
hours to do something what would
eventually become tarp or the global
financial system may collapse Wow so
when I sat down to write the book I
wanted to fact-check the story so I sent
an email to Judd Gregg and said look
this is my recollection of what you said
and he said note back saying it's all
right except the last sentence what he
said was you have 72 hours and if you
don't do something the global financial
system will collapse and Judd Gregg is
not an alarmist so we were we were
really close Mervyn King who I guess was
here recently there's a story in the
book about him you know facing the
bailout of nodes in Northern Rock right
he gets called out of a meeting and his
staff says you know we got to figure out
what to do about this and he says well
what if I don't do anything and they
said well then we believe that the ATM
machines will stop working all
everywhere he said you know in that
inimitable British way you haven't left
me much choice then have ways and so of
course they bailed him out
so we were really close and people don't
understand counterfactual right every
will say well couldn't work look how bad
it was all the Great Depression was was
many times worse in part because we
didn't do anything we didn't do anything
effectively could you comment on a lot
of human behavior or psychology and all
this so I've come to believe that
psychology is so important in economics
in general but it's everything when it
comes to money and banking I mean as
some of the sections I read made clear
money is at bottom a psychological
creation if there's a break in trust
even under the gold standard by the way
because a lot of banks do not have
enough gold on hand to honor all the
gold certificates that have been issued
so really under any currency if for any
reason including a completely wrong
headed rumor people suddenly decide the
money's not worth anything then it's not
worth anything so on that dimension
psychology is extraordinarily important
and of course that's what leads to panic
and banking crises and all there
but it's also true you know there's now
the subfield of economics called
behavioral economics that I would argue
the discipline has gotten much better
when you move away from this idea that
people are automotives that act
rationally in all circumstances to
embrace what Shakespeare certainly knew
which is we're jealous and short-sighted
and and all the rest and you plug that
into the models human behavior and
things make a lot more sense so I think
that some of the greatest developments
including a Nobel Prize have been at
this intersection of psychology
economics and now of course cognitive
brain science where we can watch people
make decisions and confirm what
Shakespeare also knew so I think it's
really really important and grossly
underappreciated certainly for a very
long time last one well actually I have
to okay that's okay
the first is you mentioned the feds role
as a regulatory body so I'd like to hear
more about that I'm also curious about
the u.s. status as world reserve
currency
what's the feds role in maintaining that
or how does that restrict their action
all right let's see whether it'll
survive yeah ah well the dollar is not a
great reserve currency except for all
the other options I mean to paraphrase
Winston Rosario you're going to go to
the Euro or the yen where you've got
deflation they just aren't many other
options there was you know yuan in China
where there's not much transparency
about decisions that are being made
capital controls still in place and so
on so for the if I had to bet I'd say
for the foreseeable future it's going to
remain the reserve currency just for
lack of good options it's not by the way
certain that it's a great thing but you
know it is certainly true that allows us
more leeway on the central banking side
than we would otherwise have it's easier
for us to borrow because central banks
around the world want to hold reserve
reserves in dollars and so on but it's
not clear when you look at fiscal policy
that be having it's so easy to borrow is
going to work out really well for us in
the long run in some ways it creates
some very bad habits and those may in
the end come back to bite us I'm
discussion for another day very
concerned about the US fiscal situation
the debt and so on and and the first
question was the feds role is oregano
fed rose alright so just first and
foremost I was very praised I praise the
feds response to 2008 but it's also true
that one of the most egregious failings
before 2008 was also the Fed and that
was on the regulatory front the Fed had
the greatest capacity and authority had
they opted to use it to crack down on
the mortgage market the subprime
mortgage market and all the other things
that was clear by 2008 that lending
standards were a total farce about 2005
my dog was pre-approved for a Visa card
with an $18,000 credit limit that was a
sign things may have gotten out of
control so I think Ben Bernake and
others would concede that they missed
that regulatory boat the question is
have they fixed the problem and
theoretically I support everything that
dodd-frank tried to do which is okay if
you've got a financial system that if
there are problems it spreads and
affects innocent parties then there's a
compelling reason for regulation the
analogy I like a lot is if you're
smoking in bed and you live in the
middle of Wyoming it's your problem if
you are smoking in bed and you live in
Georgetown it's our problem and
therefore there are layers of kinds of
things we're going to try and do so
we're going to say you can't smoke and
dead right that's not a crazy regulation
now we may think you're going to do it
anyway so we'll say okay you also have
to have sprinklers which is to say even
if people do stupid things and banks
will because they are human do stupid
things we can still contain the damage
so a lot of the regulation is stop the
stupid behavior failing that contain the
damage and then the last is kind of
systemically important risk there are
now controls in place that say if you as
an institution are so important that if
something goes wrong even sprinklers
aren't going to save it let's say you're
a skyscraper then we will give extra
vigilance to what you are doing so
theoretically this all makes sense the
question is can you actually do that and
one of the nice things about doing the
book is the last per
and I spoke to was Ben Bernanke because
run through all the ideas in the book
and he pointed out what other people
know which is that regulation inherently
builds a fence which is to say okay you
can't smoke in bed but people who want
to smoke in bed will say this isn't the
bed it's a sofa right and so now you
know that's how you get it you get
another ten pages of regulations on what
a bed is right in fact it's true like
when cigarette taxes went up you had a
boot of boom in the sale of small cigars
I don't throw out like cigarettes right
so the question he broached and it's
still unanswered is have we built the
fence sufficiently so that we can ward
off what we know has always come which
is some kind of financial panic have we
either eliminated the most egregious
behavior you know things like the Volker
Rohr designed to limit activities that
might go bad or have we contained it the
equivalent of sprinklers would be
capital controls which is you can do
stupid things but you have to have more
capital on your balance sheet so when it
goes bad you won't go bust and the
things like living wills that okay even
if you go bust we're going to have the
documents in place that say you won't
pull the rest of us down with you so
theoretically everything the dodd-frank
tried to do is what we need to do I have
no idea whether it's going to be
successful in I think that's the history
of the regulation of Finance we're
always one crisis behind unfortunately
so on forth that's a bad note to end on
uh-huh but thank you very much for
coming out
[Applause]
well thank you very much for coming out
ladies and gentlemen I think it's fair
to say that in just over an hour we've
learned a huge amount about the world of
money and so just imagine what reading
the whole book will do is a fascinating
read I urge you all to read it please do
stay and have your book signed and say
hello and thank you very much for coming
and thank you very much Charles wheeler